l'hommage d'ajaccio ce matin au préfet
erignac à l'endroit même où il a été
assassiné par balles
il y a tout juste quatre ans une plaque
a été dévoilée en sa mémoire
plus de 300 personnes ont assisté à son
inauguration
au même moment paris commémorait tôt si
cet anniversaire funèbres l'occasion
pour dominique erignac sa veuve d'en
appeler aux candidats à la présidence
afin que l'assassin de son mari soit
enfin arrêté j'ai toujours demandé
interpellé le président de la république
et le premier ministre parce que mon
mari est à presser il fait partie de
l'état
et eux ils vont être candidat l'enquète
sur le meurtre de claude érignac le 6
février 98 abouti à l'arrestation de
huit nationalités se corse
mais son assassin présumé yvan colonna
ans demeure introuvable
la justice est tenue en échec mais
lionel jospin réaffirme lui son
optimisme je ne doute pas que la justice
de mon pays que les forces dé sécurité
y parviendront ce jour là yvan colonna
assassin présumé aura à rendre des
comptes à la justice
le procès des membres du commando au
sein devrait avoir lieu à la fin de
cette année en attendant la traque divan
colonna continue